considera la curva dada por que cubica
menos xy igualados se puede mostrar que
la derivada de con respecto a x es igual
ayer entre 3 y cuadrada - x inciso a
escribe la ecuación de la recta tangente
a la curva en el punto menos 11 y bueno
podemos encontrar la ecuación de una
recta si sabemos su pendiente y también
un punto por donde pasa la recta esta
información es suficiente para encontrar
la ecuación de la recta entonces
cualquier recta se puede escribir de la
forma bien es igual a m x
y bueno también sabemos que la pendiente
va a ser igual la pendiente va a ser
igual a la derivada de 100 con respecto
a x esto en este punto que tengo aquí y
también ya sabemos a cuánto va a ser
igual esto es cuando x vale menos 1 y
lleva de 1 porque este punto vive en la
curva
entonces si sustituimos estos valores
justo aquí voy a obtener bueno
aquí tengo james pero ya en este punto
vale 1 bien ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre 3 porque al cuadrado
bueno uno cuadrados uno por tres estrés
ya esto hay que quitarle x el valor de x
en este punto que es menos 1
entonces me va a quedar 1 entre 3 -
menos uno bueno eso es lo mismo que tres
más uno
me va a dar un cuarto la pendiente de
esta recta es de un cuarto entonces
nuestra ecuación de la recta será james
es igual a la pendiente que vale un
cuarto por x + b y tenemos que averiguar
cuánto vale b y ahora para obtener ave
vamos a utilizar este punto que tengo
aquí porque nosotros sabemos que el
punto menos 11 está en la recta entonces
podemos usar esta información para
obtener a ver esta recta es tangente a
la curva lo que quiere decir que
incluyen a este punto y sólo a ese punto
de la curva es lo único que tienen en
común la curva y la recta entonces
usémoslo cuando llévale uno me queda un
cuarto que multiplica a equis pero en
este punto x vale menos uno y esto
entonces me queda uno es igual a menos
un cuarto más b y si ahora sumó un
cuarto de ambos lados me va a quedar que
b es igual a bueno me queda un entero un
cuarto un entero un cuarto o lo que es
lo mismo cinco cuartos o también lo
podemos ver como 1.25 de lujo lo podemos
escribir de cualquiera de estas tres
maneras entonces la ecuación de la recta
tangente a la curva en ese punto
va a ser bien igual a la pendiente que
es un cuarto que multiplica a x + b pero
ve vale y lo voy a escribir así cinco
cuartos
y ya con esto hemos acabado esta primera
parte de este problema
este primer inciso